siete tanti devo dire vedendovi da qua
siete tanti dopo la spiegazione di oggi
aveva visto tutti questi belli speaker
che parlavano di idee di più che altre
parlavano di di quello della scienza di
quello che ci circonda
parliamo di qualcosa un po più leggero
visto che siamo dopo pranzo quindi
magari è un tema o po più leggero ma che
comunque si ricollega a quello che di
cui hanno parlato i nostri relatori
stamattina vi introduco evo focalizza su
che altro sul significato delle parole
che vedrete su questa presentazione
nel 2009 parte un progetto che si chiama
open design italia con un gruppo di
persone soprattutto una persona che qua
presente con me che è la rosolini è un
progetto per noi innovativo e diverso
che parte dalle esperienze personali
designer quindi tutti design e magari in
sala ce ne saranno molti e spero che
magari mondo uscirete da questa
presentazione volete anche voi essere
far parte di questo fantastico mondo e
parte l'idea e vogliamo far capire che
cosa sta nascendo
open e apertura che cos'è l'apertura a
un tipo di design diverso che sta
nascendo da dieci anni in nord europa ma
anche in italia si chiama open design
italia e all'evento che
in qualche modo fa enfatizza le
creatività e designer che seguono
l'autoproduzione piccola serie piccola
serie che sono oggetti creati dai design
e quindi il design è protagonista del
nostro evento perché abbiamo creato un
manifestazione in una manifestazione
basata su un concorso di idee dove
partecipano e ogni designer espone e
vende i propri oggetti oggetti realmente
realizzati è più che altro che infatti
sono quello che la creatività e la
produttività del territorio italiano ma
anche internazionale è un concorso
quindi internazionale e quindi sul tema
del design
il design quindi a un e largo a un
prende qualsiasi
tema in questo momento ma ci siamo
focalizzati soprattutto su il made in
europe e quello che è
l'internazionalizzazione cioè il
designer che vengono a noi espongono
quest'anno sono 90 dopo una selezione di
più di 250 iscritti da paese
dall'ungheria la francia la birmania new
york su tutti i paesi e comunque vengono
e vogliono esporre e far vedere le
proprie idee di design e sono
protagonisti di questo evento i progetti
che vedete alle mie spalle sono
realmente venduti nella mostra che
avrete magari spero a vedere a novembre
cosa è anche un bacino di idee perché
open design italia deve essere visto non
solo come una mostra mercato un concorso
o semplicemente una vetrina per i
designer ma anche per le stesse aziende
perché in questo momento periodo storico
diciamo la cosa fondamentale sono le
idee che devono nascere appunto dal
basso max tutto dovesse concrete e
soprattutto da comportare innovazione e
questo è una normale azienda che produce
design lo sa benissimo perché ha una
ricerca deve fare anche ricerca di
mercato questo è faticato anche quelli
sono distretti produttivi non solo
italiane ma anche esteri
quello che ci ha portato poi a capire
stavamo andando una reazione giusta sono
i risultati
questo è il primo evento fatto nel 2010
a modena e al foro boario ha portato
4.000 visitatori solo esclusivamente con
poche energia 2011 abbiamo fatto a
bologna e poi successivamente 2012 siamo
arrivati in un altro territorio che
d'altro territorio in realtà è sempre
l'italia che a venezia
questi risultati ci hanno portato poi a
capire che stavamo andando alla
direzione giusta per enfatizzare quello
che era il vero progetto open design
italia la terza parola italia perché
vogliamo sottolineare il fatto che il
progetto è nato in italia non si parla
ai miei vista chi è nato in italia
l'anno scorso abbiamo chiesto ad ogni
designer di descriverci quelle che sono
le la fase produttiva e l'ideazione cioè
dove nasce quindi abbiamo creato la
carta d'identità dell'oggetto per il
designer abbiamo chiesto tutte e tutti
gli esami che partecipavano al nostro
nostra manifestazione di presentare la
carta identità perché l'utente finale ha
bisogno di comprare degli oggetti e che
sappia realmente come vengono realizzati
questo poi ha portato che cosa a farci
capire che ci sono dei distretti forti
produttivi in italia dove il design si
lega con artigiani piccole e medie
aziende ma anche anche aziende più
grandi il design a in questa situazione
vuol capire infatti dal territorio
infatti da l'artigianalità e soprattutto
in questo momento fa capire che cosa
sono le due cose importanti e sono
spinto per me a lauro a portare avanti
il suo progetto la prima è infatti dare
il fatto delle relazioni le persone
voglio venire a comprare sapere quello
che c'è dall'altra parte la seconda cosa
fondamentale e le relazioni
internazionali cioè far capire ad ogni
designer che quello che sta facendo sta
andando a direzione giusta ma il vero
risultato qual è
noi in questo percorso di tre anni
abbiamo partite all idea dobbiamo andare
avanti cioè dobbiamo far capire che cosa
sta veramente
nascendo in questo momento e ci siamo
posti questa domanda questa è la
classica filiera produttiva che vedete
per quanto riguarda le aziende del
design ripeto il nostro è il
intestazione parla di un mercato
parallelo che non si contrappone a
quella che normalmente la filiera
produttiva dell'industrial design però
come vedete emergono che cosa mergono
fondamentalmente l'azienda e l'utente
finale vede quello che compra ma non sa
chi sono i soggetti i secondi soggetti
perché come sapete il progetto parte da
un prototipo ci sono delle idee vengono
concretizzate e poi si passano filiera
produttiva poi abbiamo guardato il
processo produttivo dell'autoproduzione
quindi la piccola serie e abbiamo capito
che emergeva il designer sempre di più
c'è una grande figura però tutto quello
era connesso sempre al di sotto design
non emergeva in questo momento allora ci
siamo posti le problematiche in tutte e
due le produttivi sono pro dema
problematiche il problematica dei due
soggetti soggetti che non si relazionano
spesso perché hanno problemi un
artigiano un designer l'azienda somma su
meccanismi difficili perché comunque
sono persone che si diano relazionare la
seconda problematica era
fondamentalmente la commercializzazione
distribuzione che è difficile poter
diffondere i questo questo tipo di
mercato anche perché il designer che
vedrete esporre la nostra mostra hanno
già un sito vendono tramite e commerce
hanno già una diffusione molto larga di
quelli che sono i progetti che realmente
producono e poi vendono da noi
ma il quello che ci ha portato avanti
quello per cui vogliamo andare avanti da
adesso in poi è il progetto che poi ci
ha spinto a vincere spinner 2013 cioè
creare una factory che cosa significa
significa che puntonet e network per noi
significa creare delle relazioni che
sono quelle normalmente dette network
può essere sia internet sia tutto quello
che i media ma realtà quello che
dobbiamo vogliamo riscoprire sono quelle
che sono le relazioni personali perché
le idee sono belle 5 sono idee ma devono
essere concrete e le concretezza si
realizza invece in realtà quando si
abbiamo le relazioni di persone quindi
abbiamo creato open design italia
factory che cos'è abbiamo preso i nostri
vincitori designer delle passate
edizioni e le abbiamo poi connesse ad
artigiani artigiani del territorio siamo
partiti col primo esempio adesso con
design factory punto zero che cosa sono
sono i designer che si relazionano
artigiani e stiamo producendo gli
oggetti con un tema e abbiamo dato il
tema del nomadismo cioè e oggetti
realmente che l'utente finale possa
realmente
comprare e avere quindi una relazione
direttamente con con noi e la mission è
quella di
fondamentalmente di esprimere quello che
il territorio che facevo vedere prima
nella mappa dell'italia la creatività la
produttività perché ogni designer si
relazione appunto a un artigiano del
posto e quindi a un'azienda del
territorio
ma
tutto questo ci ha portato anche a ca
farci capire che non basta sulla
creatività non basta solo le idee non
basta solo la produttività ma ci servono
dei servizi è più che altro bisogna far
capire anche il valore aggiunto di
questa nostra nuova piattaforma che cosa
sono che fino alla filiera produttiva
che avevate visto fino adesso ai mezzi
dal designer o mese va all'azienda ma in
realtà non 10 effettivamente la figura
dell'artigiano quindi con questo tipo di
progetto abbiamo cercato di connettere
nel nec nel network connettere alla
factory i due soggetti e falli ma è
crescere nella stessa maniera quindi
nella prossima carta d'identità che voi
vedete degli oggetti che esporranno da
noi sulla realtà oggetti che vengono
creati e ideati dagli artigiani che
avranno stesso
d'entrambe due figure stesso guadagno e
comunque anche stessa visibilità
significa quindi semplicemente quelle
parole chiave che vedete qua al mie
spalle
cioè il fatto di creare questo rapporto
tra i due soggetti e poi più che altro
aiutarli nella promozione distribuzione
degli stessi oggetti che verranno creati
e aiutarli anche nella formazione
dell'assistenza perché abbiamo visto in
questi anni che i designer o comunque
partecipanti espositore la nostra mostra
vengono però hanno bisogno anche di un
supporto spesso sono preparati magari
sulla produttività ma non sanno molto
quello che è inerente a come
relazionarci con l'utente finale come
poter emancipare crescere e far vedere
quello che realmente fanno e quindi
emergere anche tra i diversi talenti
sottolinea il fatto che l'evento open
design italia e porterà quindi sarà
l'evento che sarà la parte fulcro su cui
poi si baserà alla factory quindi sono
quello che vogliamo far capire che
tramite questo bando di concorso c'è una
forte selezione cioè situazione in cui
partono veramente non sanno realmente se
vogliono fare del design stanno
producendo degli oggetti in questa
realtà loro emergono e quindi molte
realtà che stanno nascendo dal 2010
sempre sul tema della produzione devo
dire che stanno facendo
che stanno creando altre situazioni
stanno trovando scouting su di noi
perché noi facciamo emergere proprio dal
basso delle situazioni che poi emergono
vincitori del nostro evento sono
arrivati a esporre a manifestazioni
internazionali ed inguaia di berlino
addirittura produrre con grandi aziende
tipo se letti sono quindi per farvi
capire che non è solo importante l'idea
ma poi bisogna passare anche
all'esecutività dello stesso oggetto
continuando sulla factor quindi noi
parliamo di oggetti design quindi in
relazione la factory e questi sono
esempi di oggetti che sono già stati
prodotti dai designer che sono
partecipato alle nostre passate edizioni
ma che enfatizzano la qualità degli
oggetti che voi potete comprare perché
appunto la mostra mercato
quindi quello che sottolineamo che i
soggetti più importanti per noi sono
quelli che producono idea un oggetto ma
anche l'utente finale cioè voi che
venite a comprare perché lo voi dovete
capire fondamentalmente avere una
trasparenza della filiera produttiva e
quindi capire magari che quell'oggetto è
stato veramente creato vicino a casa
vostra
e poi ci serve far capire anche quelli
che sono non più quegli accessi virtuali
degli oggetti ma arrivare a una
infestazione come la nostra e poter
trovare veramente degli oggetti
veramente concretamente producibili ma
anche vendibile
quindi
l'open design italia che cos'è
fondamentalmente per noi è un progetto
stiamo portando avanti da diversi da
questi versi anni che mi stavo dicendo e
vuole anche per proporsi come quello che
è la factory perché siamo convinti che
le idee sono sempre positive ma che
comunque devono avere un risultato anche
un riscontro
quindi vi aspetto tutti il dal 22 al 24
novembre a venezia perché la nostra
vetrina in cui si accompagna da due anni
e vedrete design e che vengono a tutto
veramente il mondo perché la selezione
del concorso è stata fatta qualche
settimana fa e portato degli ottimi
risultati è più che altro venite a
comprare perché queste sono tutte idee
diverse voi troverete oggetti che
esprimono non solo il territorio alle
attività dei singoli ma esprimo anche un
tipo speciale di produttività e di
materiale perché sono già tutti diversi
perché proprio perché i soggetti sono
diversi quindi vi ringrazio e grazie di
essere così tanti